okie-dokie ah escape oh yes okay yeah
what to talk through here uh sir so they
go to the they go to the Citadel they
find he's dead and but the Lich starts
to break three free because it's just so
evil he has evil stuff that turns all
the other bad guys into his bad guys and
they break Finn's father out of his name
is Martin and he's just a total dead
beat bum dance pretty much and it has no
interest in his son is only you know
he's kind of like playful and friendly
but just clearly has no responsibilities
or deque Asians of anything and there's
the stuff that puts his leg back
together because it gets her fried off
so they use that to defeat the Lynch and
that turns him to a great big baby baby
which I couldn't have seen that coming
but when Martin's trying to get away
with all the other villains uh Finn
tries to match on and he gets so
involved in getting his dad back and
getting some answers that his arm the
grass part starts to grow like thorns
and it starts to grow bigger and bigger
I grow so big and the force is so strong
his arm is literally ripped off and he
falls off and a little bit of that gunk
that makes your skin the whole again
Guardians
yeah like the Guardians blood whatever
was gets on his arm because little
flower cute and cute and he's really sad
and even Shelby comes out to shed a few
tears and if there was actually really -
I love how even a worm is more affected
by everything that his dad is I mean
that was kind of like the big out Shiva
moment and in probably the biggest
laughs we see the first time we see mr.
pig and tree trunks after they got
married she's about this
just they get a divorce but that there's
a baby the ledge lift at their door
stopping that what this changes
everything which is very ironic
considering the whole story about how
you know if in was left behind it's just
like I didn't quite know how to take all
that really but um I liked it had a lot
of fun adventurous stuff the the
deadbeat dad I mean with Skye Bobby
she's gonna be free Oh Larry you know
that not a guard um I had a feeling in
my go that direction it's and yet it was
still so painful to watch that that
stuff is just hard and ever on me a
little bit you guys are to see Cowboy
Bebop yeah I met member Ed's dead oh
yeah yeah it remind me a lot of bad oh
yeah
where I think with him with him though
it was just a sense like his marbles
weren't all there I mean it was just
constantly distracted it was like you
know super super super super super ad D
you know something like that where like
you see like you know he liked his kid
you know I come on you want be with the
old man now you want to go and then just
uh work and he just takes off like he's
not actively trying to get rid of her he
just don't think here he is actively
like trying to push the son away and
it's just like Marie confessed her he is
really fast there yeah you know you have
to go a little quicker and just in such
a the way I can describe it such a did
beat way cuz he tries to do it all
friendly yeah a little quick in there
could you know it is just like that
stuff is even more painful than if he
was like you know I don't want you or
something like that it's that kind of
friendliness that out of maybe it's more
like realistic we've seen a few versions
that it shows the little parts where he
calls them Flynn yeah because the name
my god it might be a little bit of a
place this is like private opposed rerun
thing ever the The Fresh Prince where
his dad comes back yeah I mean it's just
like yep honestly rightfully so be
played over and over again
it's from water components like an
incredible episode and yeah it's just
kind of that same thing where it's early
well if I if I act tonight you see an
artist are saying nice-ish things it's
like I'm not such a bad guy
yeah okay and stuff and clearly this guy
had the same mindset and he's just so
just he's dislikable enough to still
enjoy a little bit like I still laugh a
little bit what he's like you know okay
you know okay ever give up jeez I mean
I'm just like how can this guy just be
so soulless yeah but I almost thought
the joke was gonna be it actually wasn't
his father I thought that'd be kind of
come all this way just like oh yeah go
do that so I'm going to the head turns
out wasn't the father um but the fact
that it is makes even more painful so
yeah I thought it's still a but it's
still had the last they had a lot of
creativity with the different creatures
and a lot of energy to it as well and
even with what a Debbie he was it still
has some good
chuckles with it and my guess is with
the flower growing out of the arm i I
was guessing because he had the grass
blade part of his arm but maybe that's
like it mixed together or something
that's where the flower came from that's
my best guess
I'm curious to see what they do with
that now it's like just as a flower for
not I mean at this point in time I mean
your guess is as good as mine there's
not many episodes after this point in
time so unlike before I'm like ha ha ha
ha I know all what's happening I you
know now I'm kind of like yeah your
guess is as good as mine you know so
it's kind of neat for me like now like
I'm in that whole exciting like yeah
yeah no okay to Jory
I loved it I absolutely loved it and it
was so so horrific it was so sad to see
Finn I mean just I don't know the
desperation I guess is more than
anything it was just so so desperate
even knowing even seeing it's like right
there you almost want to scream at him
don't you see he's a horrible person
he's a piece of crap
well Jake actually yells at Adam pretty
much I felt like I wanted to just scream
in him but I mean it just there's
nothing you can do and I feel like this
it's painful and it's it's it's so very
real it's painful because it's so very
real there are so many people out there
that have awful parents whether they're
neglectful or they're abusive or
for whatever reason you know and in your
own way you're constantly trying to get
that approval you're constantly trying
to get them to acknowledge you and you
know they're horrible people but they're
still your parents and you just still
want batts you know there's this ideal
of a parents and you want it and it just
it felt a little a lot real I thought it
was nicely done she'll be coming out was
probably the saddest thing I've ever
seen look he has crawled up like a
little puppy I look it was and you know
and it was like it wasn't even and as I
was watching that like in my head too I
was like oh my god I mean yes the arm
but it's not the arm like I just felt
like Shelby wasn't praying so much for
the arm as he was for Finn's
loss of his father all over again that
was you know so traumatic like you know
yes the arm it's horrible but just how
he lost it why he lost it was even worse
than the fact that he lost it
this is a lot you know something I
realized I just thought right now too is
that you know they're all telling you no
Finn come on doing you know he's a loser
and stuff and literally you have him
holding on and he's not letting go you
know and when he doesn't let go a part
of famous take it away
mhm you know and yeah that's yeah you
know and again a flower starts to grow
there's like you know something is taken
away but something starts to grow again
yeah hopefully it'll get bigger and
stronger and will it be the same no but
it'll it's still the growth of something
else yeah to replace it so yeah it's
very clever some lines like to show like
to me it you're right in the sense of if
you just sat there was like go away from
me you're a scumbag like him talking to
Finn you know Martin talking to Finn
he's just a go away I want you whatever
like okay that's one thing you go you're
an asshole
well like just the way yeah he says
things when Finn puts the gook on his
leg when he grows back and he looks just
like I can't even fix the boot yeah
something as minor as that it wasn't
even a thank you
it was just he was looking like oh you
couldn't do more yeah you know expecting
even more from them or crap what's the
other one that I was just thinking about
it he says it with the smile on his face
oh yes it's also it's very manipulative
yeah yes yes absolutely yes he's a
communist and that's more or less when
it comes down to um oh the other one was
you know we're Finn's like he blurts out
really really fast why did you leave me
in the poorest yeah he's like I don't
know maybe you left me you know and it
was like can't even say it in a joking
tone you know he was like well maybe you
left me you know it's like wow
you couldn't even
your accent trying to make that as an
honest excuse like instead of trying to
pull it off as a joke or something he
was singing like so seriously like he
maybe you'll buy this everything is the
opportunity it's not one yeah one can I
do for anyone else it's always what can
you do for me yeah what can I do for me
and I'm sure it's like whatever the
circumstance of having a kid it's like
well it doesn't benefit me much of
course I don't want that yeah you know
what's a baby gonna do for me yeah the
only problem I didn't have with this was
what they did with the Lich from what I
gathered beforehand the Lich is
basically all evil all that stuff you
gotta gotta Jana the Lich came about
from the bomb going off you know and now
they've given the Lich like a pre Lich
form I always took it as the Lich was
created because of the bomb itself like
he was part of the bomb he wasn't some
baby skeleton that reacted with you know
the oh my god the bomb and turned into
the Lich
he was just kind of like this almost
like an essence if you will that existed
when the bomb went off it gave that
essence life well but couldn't you if
you throw that gunk on him and he you
know couldn't it just be what the gun
transforms him into I me on see it looks
more to me like the skin was sort of
like not taking a weight but kind of
covering the power is like kind of
muting them and it's like still kind of
trapped inside cuz he's still the same
size - yeah no I know
actually he's even he's bigger yeah
really really big but when you when he
put it on Martin when Finn put her on
Martin it grew back it's like normally
so I took it as the blood brings things
back to how they were a healing agent if
you will look about then didn't have a
flower but only at what only a tiny
amount landed there
it wasn't coated so I mean and I just
felt again I don't know I felt they
didn't know what to do with the Lich
they didn't know how to fight
we finish off the Lich for good the
lights just such a great village he is
like a top-notch villain that yeah you
just there's nothing you can do but
that's also writing yourself into a
corner and by sitting there going oh
we're gonna take the ultimate evil and
turning it into a baby I'm just going
like really that is merely the route you
want to go I'm really paranoid cuz
you're right because he is so
threatening and you know and all the
stuff he's done so the idea of yeah just
turning him into a baby is and sir that
dumbbell ending which I thought was
really funny but you're but you're right
it's still what happened last episode
yeah like it kills the old man they're
dumb and you said yourself you're like
oh you know what I mean it's it's
it's cheapening it I know they did it
for a laugh or whatever maybe they have
something coming in the future I don't
know but it felt like what can we do
what can we do I will turn him into a
baby that would be hilarious because we
need more nothing babies and now we're
gonna see more tree trunks you be yeah I
mean this is this is a character that
has killed off you know some major
characters and yes are the idea that he
would end on it joke you're right
doesn't feel right and maybe they would
bring him back in some sort of other way
I don't know but yeah something does
seem a little off about that even though
I think it is funny ya know I I find it
funny but then again I thought about and
I'm like nah you know come on really
this is what you it just seems like a
wussy way to end it but then again if
you were raised by tree trunks you'd
probably turn out to be the ultimate
evil we'll see if it happens again you
know I'd say in fact they even brings up
a good point you're talking about we get
to see more tree trunks with the baby
now whatever and I was thinking to
myself you know watching that all I
would think is oh my gosh the Lich can
go back to how he oh my god would he
kill tree trunks oh my god and it's like
that these don't match it should be more
of the comedic possibilities of the Lich
which tree trunks would be funny but
it's like no I'd be like really
concerned for tree trunks and it's like
that's not
something's not meshing very you're
right it's kind of these two things
they're usually very good balancing out
but those two don't quite go together I
think they were just going for the joke
oh yeah that's that's like I said I
don't they figured out exactly what to
do with them and they're gonna have to
get rid of them or anything I mean they
could just whatever frozen again upon
somewhere else and he's like the guy
creates the the portals and all that
stuff or whatever
don't put the gunk out turn him into a
normal human or something and now he
have to figure out how to get his power
thing it you know something like use why
didn't he regress why did he turn into a
baby when he was a full-grown man you
know it's it's healing agent yeah I get
that and I get that Finn or Jake pretty
much said he's born again but it just
seemed very counteractive considering
healing the leg and all that stuff or
maybe the blood just does what it's
supposed to do yeah it affects everyone
differently which I guess that's sort of
what I was maybe thinking that yeah I
wasn't sure what you know I mean I guess
I just took the blood to do whatever it
felt was necessary at the moment you
know again with Finn's arm or lack of
arm with the flower growing I know you
said it's just a small drop but I just I
just wondered about it Plus also my
first thought actually when the Lynch
was starting to grow skin and bone ins
from tendons and muscle and stuff
my first thought actually was oh my god
life is killing him oh that would have
been interesting actually because he was
getting covered in life yeah like he was
dead
he's nothing essentially he's a skeleton
this very symbol of death and
nothingness and he brings death and so
to be covered in flesh and
and and muscle and all this living stuff
and being covered in living stuff I
thought that was my first thought was
life was killing that well you could
argue it still kind of it what is the
best way for life to kill death okay of
life birth yeah yeah it does kind of
make sense I still don't like it I don't
think that's I we might be reading too
deep into and I think we are and I think
people are probably gonna like no that's
totally what they were going for died
yeah I felt it was - to quote the modern
teens I thought it was a punk ass way of
taking out a great villain I felt it was
lame I felt it was cheap I thought they
had no idea what to do with the Lich and
for a villain like a great villain it
felt you're right he went out on a cheap
joke to me it was just yeah enjoy your
explanation is pretty needs and it's
actually an interesting way of looking
at it but I don't think that's what they
were looking at I don't buy it
honestly I mostly agree with you but her
true theory is so interesting I'm I'm
leaning towards the problem what it's
all my way into saying OK and
and I'll say ok I'll buy that yeah no
honestly because it's it's not a vent
theory really I'm kind of like ok like
that would very much legitimately
explain why you would be a baby and it
wouldn't it wouldn't just leave it on
dumb joke it would be like this actually
does kind of make sense but believe
leaving up leaving them in the hands of
mr. pig and tree trunks like I said that
that still even though it's movie versus
nurture
tree trunks and mr. pig yeah yeah life
is killing death I think that sound
and we lost Ron Perlman now yeah well
you might come we don't know maybe the
evils
wrong it'll come back or yeah with
tree-trunk see it be I don't want see
treatments I look at that way you can
see tree trunks die no tree trunks is
not gonna die and that's the problem we
get the terrible tree trunks living with
the terrible Lich baby yeah no I forgot
to mention by the way you get the same
two different mommy somebody made me a
little tree trunks figurine with a
dystocia critic cat and a tie and I know
I did bring it up bring it up again
because it's worth it what about the
creepy guy who brought give you the tree
trunk stuffed animal it was like oh yeah
you brought me that too but he he just
bought that thank you still like a
sculpture and I'm thankful for both but
the the sculpture is just gonna win
sorry oh that forgot some lady who came
from France and all that stuff
apparently said it's because of me that
she started drinking do so there's to do
and I will be doing oh don't you steal
my thunder you're welcome France look at
his face this is great he's like no
gonna drink properly just now so you've
had years of training to drink do here's
to you my friends thank you baby
tell me more about your thoughts of the
Big Bang Theory and so forth where life
came from fascinating oh yeah but you
know she could sign language you racist